Elias asking do you have any tips for
people like me who have a short
concentration span and get distracted
easily yeah I mean Mike's it for you
would be to eliminate those distractions
like just just get them out of the way
so if you're distracted by certain
websites install a website blocker
that's going to block it during certain
times and like physically make it
impossible for you to visit those
websites if you're distracted by um you
know your environment um clean up your
environment so if you're cluttered desk
is distracting you then you know just
book that 25 minutes to clean up that
desk you don't get where it needs to be
um I absolutely recommend so if you're
kind of a solopreneur you work from home
um if you have the ability to work in an
office or in a room with a closed door I
think that's really helpful um i think
for me personally and again you know
this is going to vary person by person
but if i'm working on my couch you know
because I on occasion I work from home
if I'm working on my couch I'm
distracted by everything you know like
my my wife was home with my son
distracted by that on the TV is right
there even if I want to have it on for
white noise that's a distraction um use
it can be a blessing or a curse when
you're trying to be productive so really
just like creating the perfect
environment where you can't physically
be distracted because you've done your
best to to get them out of your your
view right your preferable for you on
that would be my absolute number one
suggestion and my other suggestion is if
you physically can't do that um see if
you can change your environment all
together right so like for a lot of
people going to the local coffee shop
for the local library that forces them
to get in the zone you know like you're
going to that place with focus and
purpose you're going to that location to
get things done so when you get there
you know why you're not distracted by
all the people walking by which is again
a possible possibility for some people
um you will get things done I love it um
the things that helped me earlier my
career which is
closing down email yeah and having set
times to open it up that alone save me
massive amounts of distraction you
already mentioned some of the app so you
can use about rescue time where it's
blocking pages so that you can't load
facebook for the next X number of
minutes so I love I don't agree with
everything with Tom said about the
environment the thing I would add to it
is I I'm a big believer in trying to
create a schedule that supports who you
are instead of trying to fight it and
especially as an entrepreneur you have
the ability to create your own schedule
you're not being told moved to show up
by this amount of time so if you find
that you you have you know maybe a baby
D and you can't focus for long periods
of time don't try to create a schedule
where you book yourself like three hour
chunks that may be too long for you to
get something done in I would instead
try to split up my day so I'm doing if
it's using the Promotora technique and
I'm doing you know an hour at a time
with breaks in between and I know like
I'm a guy now who is like Elias if you
are super distracted and have a TD and
you can't focus then run with that and
do our chunks hour and then break out on
a break and then you know that you're
setting up a schedule that's kind of
designed around who you are your
personality that's going to work for you
as entrence we have that ability and you
should like some people are night owls
work at night some people love the work
in the morning work first thing in the
morning right create a schedule that
supports you just as a general like
happiness rule but it also make you a
lot more productive and get you closer
to your goals faster